трагедія сталася 17 липня 2014 року
року
того дня малазійський боїнг mh17 був збитий
і над входом України всі 290 висимо люду
і заглянув і вище за два ти ж не
якщо чая група змогла по стежку ти на
місця краху
той же приватний закладено експертно
група журналістів білінг від дзвінок у
британії
почала владне розслідування у
Інтернеті youtube різьблених місцях та у
означають зрубають знімки навіть на їх основі
можна бачити цю картину того, що вигляд
був осі нас правді за словами
журналістики російський зенітно-ракетний
комплекс бук
та й піску катастрофи лайнера тут тієї ж
бук стиль квжд задньої її ракети
журналісти передалися і броні до кози
міжнародний з групою яке
киру ить експерт із нідерландів видно
зданому та розслідування чи так бог
забуту ракету з буком нібито бухнула
виливу вигляд лайнера захисні європейських
країни то україна обожнюючі ракета була
запущена з території та q контролювати
проросійські сепаратисти вона все
запара чаю дзвону взагалі катастрофі
київську владу тим часом журналісти
склади список 20 російських сирійських
служба xiv 53 зенітно-ракетної бригади та
до притчетт треба крах равликів om bogat
прийди до ви службу всього підрозділу
виколола інформацію у соцмережі
ми змогли встановити номер бригади людей
кивні значився командиром великим
overnight ремували наказ про запуск
ракети і ти їх буде циклоні
алана знімаючи прямих доказів розміщених
на сайтах соціальних маріш нас разок і
вона ти снів кнопку і збив mh17 дуб і
бачиш детальну інформацію про кожного
з російських скронь і служба вти в
передав і прокуратурі нідерландів
у виді обіцяв йому важливо вилікувати
яким вони матеріали і можемо його до
дати їх до розслідування